doch zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live euro nur ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
die tägliche klimakrise die kriegen wir
quasi immer neuen meldungen präsentiert
dass wir da ein problem haben das ist
eigentlich nicht mehr zu leugnen was
dagegen hilft ist vor allem co2 sparen
und da gibt es viele ansätze einer davon
ist natürlich das auto da stellt sich
jetzt die frage retten e-autos das klima
ist das der große wurf mit dem wir
dieses klima krisen problem doch noch in
den griff kriegen können oder ist das
ganze doch nur makulatur fürs gute
gewissen unsere tägliche autofahrt ist
natürlich mit einem baustein da ist dass
die frage wie können wir das ganze in
griff kriegen die wissenschaftler sind
sich einig dass man daran muss aber das
große angebot fehlt noch bei den
autobauern der deutsche
volkswagen-konzern hat heute seinen plan
vorgestellt was dort zu tun ist die
konzernstrategie für die jahre bis 2030
standen auf dem programm und das
wesentliche ziel des autobauers ist die
reduktion der co2 emissionswerte aller
seiner autos bis 2030 beziehungsweise
die jahre danach was dort genau geplant
wird das erklärt uns jetzt noch oliver
deuker
new auto heißt die neue strategie des
volkswagen-konzerns damit wollen die
wolfsburger tempo machen bei der
transformation zum software orientierten
mobilitätsanbieter bis 2030 wird es nur
wenn unsere kunden sich für bestimmte
designs eine karosserie oder marke oder
servicequalität entscheiden mehr denn je
für die marken differenzierung aus der
software und den dienst kommen rund 800
millionen euro lässt sich der konzern
allein ein neues entwicklungszentrum in
wolfsburg kosten der aufbau von software
kompetenzen mit eigenen mitarbeitern und
über firmen beteiligungen sowie das
einführen von abo diensten und
vorbereiten des autonomen fahrens sind
weitere eckpunkte des masterplans dem
experten zusammengeführt ressourcen und
know how von audi porsche und volkswagen
haben das zusammen gebracht in eine
agile unabhängige einheit bereits
milliarden investierte volkswagen in die
elektro offensive
etliche neue modelle sind in der planung
dazu kommen sechs eigene batteriezellen
werke europaweit bis 2030 soll dann die
hälfte der fahrzeugflotte rein
elektrisch fahren damit würde sich der
co2 ausstoß um rund 30 prozent
reduzieren
ja also große pläne darüber wollen wir
sprechen jetzt mit stephan weil
ministerpräsident von niedersachsen und
in dieser funktion auch im aufsichtsrat
des volkswagenkonzerns denn das land
hält 20 prozent der anteile an diesen
konzern und natürlich auch mit euch und
ihnen wie immer ihr kennt das in die
kommentare mit euren fragen und euren
meinungen oder hier an diese zdf adresse
die kennt ihr schon aber erstmal begrüße
ich herrn waren in hannover hallo herr
weil ich sie herzlich wie ist denn das
mit dem volkswagen-konzern wir haben
dann noch die schlagzeilen im kopf
dieser skandal da wurde betrogen da
wurde gelogen das ist zwar aufgearbeitet
worden aber bis in letzter konsequenz
mit den verantwortlichen ingenieuren bis
heute noch nicht wie wollen sie denn
jetzt ja den menschen glaubhaft machen
dass dass der volkswagen-konzern ernst
meint mit dem wandel zur emissionsfreien
fahren
sie haben völlig recht die schatten der
vergangenheit die sind wirklich lang und
die werden auch über den heutigen tag
hinaus reichen
wie kann man vertrauen zurückgewinnen am
ende nur indem man beweist dass man
seine lehren gezogen hat
im nachhinein wird das vielleicht so
sein dass es einmal heißen wird das
durch diesel geht bei volkswagen der
groschen noch rechtzeitig gefallen ist
jedenfalls ist man seit einigen jahren
wirklich intensiv dabei den wechsel
insbesondere richtung eines
klimaneutralen unternehmens zu schaffen
und jetzt ist man auch wirklich so weit
dass es dass man heute einen glaube ich
großen wurf vorstellen konnte volkswagen
ist vielleicht besonders weit in der
transformation ein thema das ja unsere
ganze industrie enorm beschäftigt aber
eine sache die hat heute gefehlt bei
dieser pressekonferenz da haben andere
konzerne schon wieder größere ziele
angekündigt nämlich der ausstieg aus dem
verbrennungsmotor da gab es doch gleich
kritik von greenpeace wir haben wir rein
also erstmal ohne e autos sind die
klimaziele nicht zu erreichen denn die
klimabilanz von ihr auto ist viel besser
als die von verbrechern
genauso wichtig ist aber die frage wann
vw den verkauf von 9 diese und benzinern
stoppt denn trotz der hitzewelle
überflutungen und überschwemmungen
dürren plan vw jetzt noch milliarden in
neue klimaschädliche die sind benziner
zu investieren und hat sich auch noch
kein enddatum für neue verbrenner
gesetzt die internationale
staatengemeinschaft hat sich in paris
aber darauf geeinigt die erderwärmung
auf 1,5 grad zu begrenzen um unsere
lebensgrundlage zu schützen
und davon sind die aktuellen pläne von
vw empfängt derweil was meinen sie denn
dazu war das heute vielleicht dann
tatsächlich doch nicht so ein ganz
großer wurf wenn der konzern nicht sagt
wir steigen aus bis 2030 zum beispiel
nein ich glaube man muss differenzieren
es gibt ja große regionen auf der welt
sie sind schon relativ weit wie zum
beispiel deutschland und vielleicht auch
zentraleuropa
da können wir davon ausgehen dass zum
ende des jahrzehnts wahrscheinlich
deutlich mehr als 50 60 prozent
elektromobile verkauft werden es gibt
aber auch regionen auf der welt da sind
die voraussetzungen dafür schlichtweg
nicht gegeben und volkswagen verkauft ja
seine autos über auf der ganzen welt
und unter diesen bedingungen ist es dann
glaube ich auch besser man
sparsame verbrenner dem weiterverkauft
werden
als eben solche die den sprit nur so
schlucken kann etwa sagen können derweil
gut in europa verkaufen wir dann zum
beispiel oder nordamerika verkaufen wir
keiner verbrennen bis 2030 da wo es noch
nicht geht da geht es dann halt noch
nicht da gucken wir dass wir in unserer
technologie verkaufen aber da wo es halt
funktionieren muss da muss es dann auch
funktionieren das wird einfach ganz
faktisch geschehen da bin ich sehr
sicher wir werden erleben in den
nächsten jahren das schlachthof schlafen
nicht nur volkswagen sondern jede menge
andere unternehmen ein exzellentes
elektroauto nach dem nächsten auf den
markt bringt durch die durch den co2
preis in denen jetzt intensiv
eingestiegen wird wird es immer teurer
werden ein verbrenner zu fahren und es
wird immer wirtschaftlicher werden ein
gutes elektroauto zu fahren also mit
anderen worten ich bin sehr sicher dass
wir da an der stelle eine faktische
entwicklung erleben die dazu führen wird
dass an der stelle die klimaziele in
deutschland relativ schnell erreicht
werden können weltweit sieht das dann
allerdings wahrscheinlich schon anders
aus jetzt gibt es hier eine gute frage
von blockmaster 1996 warum sollte man
sich ein auto kaufen wenn die
infrastruktur noch nicht funktioniert
also funktionieren tut sie also es gibt
infrastruktur aber ich glaube was hier
gemeint ist die ist ja noch wirklich rar
gerade in seine flächen manche
niedersachsen
da kann man dann ja schon das wissen
dass die befürchtung von einigen
irgendwo liegen bleiben zwischen
osnabrück und bremerhaven
es gibt die faustformel dass auf zehn
elektroautos eine ladestation kommen
sollte
und in diesem rahmen bewegt sich das in
deutschland und auch in niedersachsen
gerade wir werden allerdings in den
nächsten jahren ein großes hoch laufende
elektromobilität erleben und deswegen
muss die ladeinfrastruktur an der stelle
auch nachziehen
da gibt es auch entsprechende pläne
aller dem kritischen unterton in der
frage kann ich schon beipflichten dieser
hochlauf der muss schneller geschehen
insbesondere auch um dieses
henne-ei-problem auszulösen
auch zu lösen dass leute sagen naja ich
warte eben noch so lange bis ich ganz
sicher bin dass ich die
ladeinfrastruktur auch vorfinden werde
also da gibt es noch hausaufgaben zu
erledigen aber prinzipiell bin ich an
der stelle ziemlich zuversichtlich dass
er es auch schneller leben werden weil
einfach der
jetzt auch das würden sie denn dann
vielleicht den verbraucher mehr druck
machen wollen es gibt ja durchaus
stimmen in der politik die sagen zum
beispiel 2035 das muss müssen wir raus
aus dem verbrenner verkauf herr söder
zum beispiel der hat ja auch in großen
autobauer bei sich in bayern hat das
auch schon befürwortet die csu ist jetzt
nicht gerade bekannt dafür dass sie ist
was gegen verbrennungsmotoren hat wie
sehen sie das
ja ich glaube eher dass es eher noch
früher der fall sein wird dass sich das
rein faktisch entschieden hat aber die
restlichen hingen die ich genannt habe
sie werden das in den nächsten jahren
sehen alles das was jetzt und zwar dafür
ein allen automobilherstellern was da an
neuen guten elektroautos auf den markt
kommt ist einfach so viel attraktiver
dass ich einen sehr schnellen hochlauf
von elektromobilität in deutschland
erwartet ich sehe probleme er an einer
anderen stelle nämlich dass elektroautos
dann wird auch dazu beitragen müssen
dass wir co2 reduzieren und das hängt
insbesondere im thema energie darüber
sprechen wir gleich noch unter anderem
mit kerstin meier von der agora
verkehrswende ngo aber erstmal gucken
wir uns an wo eigentlich vw so steht
denn vw ist natürlich der größte
autobauer der welt aber nicht der
einzige und die anderen haben teilweise
schon ihre ziele vorgestellt unter
anderem eben auch ausstieg aus dem
verbrennungsmotor wir haben das mal
zusammengefasst
in den kommenden jahren wird es immer
mehr elektroautos auf den straßen geben
und die autobauer wollen daran verdienen
bei den rein batteriebetriebenen autos
ist vw in deutschland im ersten halbjahr
marktführer rund 36.000 stück haben die
wolfsburger verkauft auf platz zwei
tesla mit rund 14.000 e autos weltweit
ist tesla aber das maß aller dinge gilt
als technologietreiber für die gesamte
branche
das zeigt sich auch im börsenwert tesla
liegt bei 6 154 milliarden us-dollar
etwa fünfmal mehr als vw trotzdem vw ist
einer der größten autohersteller der
welt hat die ressourcen schnell und
profitabel mehr autos zu verkaufen und
klar ist bis zum jahr 2030 soll die
hälfte des vw angebots auf batterieautos
umgestellt werden dass gleiche plant
auch bmw und daimler hat ein ähnliches
ziel dort soll bis 2030 die hälfte der
autos zumindest halb elektrisch
unterwegs sein
hersteller volvo geht sogar noch weiter
bis 2030 sollen keine fahrzeuge mit
verbrennungsmotor mehr produziert werden
und autokonzerns der land ist will unter
seiner marke opel ab 2028 in europa nur
noch elektroautos anbieten
also da passiert viel darüber möchten
wir jetzt sprechen mit bei herrn weil
weiterhin aber auch mit kerstin meier
von der ngo agora verkehrswende dort
projekt weiteren fahrzeug und antriebe
bevor wir hier in die diskussion
einsteigen gucke ich mal kurz in den
kommentaren denn da sind viele kritische
kommentare mal so als beispiel habe ich
einmal von net die schreibt ich würde
mich freuen wenn der öffentliche
nahverkehr schnellstmöglich komplett
klimaneutral gestaltet wird also da
quasi der ansatz der individualverkehr
ist eigentlich nicht die lösung ich habe
mir noch in anderen kommentar gerade
gesehen dann ging es in die richtung wir
brauchen insgesamt weniger pkw und mehr
öffentliche verkehrsmittel können wir
noch darüber reden aber erstmal die
frage an sie frau meier sind denn die
autos überhaupt perfekt das klima zu
retten oder sollten wir ihr in solche
richtungen denken dass wir sagen weniger
autos mehr öffentlicher nahverkehr
zu jeder stunde und überall auch dort wo
jetzt vielleicht nur einmal in der
stunde was fährt ja also das ist kein
entweder oder
diese frage macht man nur das eine oder
das andere ich glaube das führt uns in
die falsche richtung
elektroautos sind auf jeden fall ein
ganz wichtiger bestandteil wenn man über
die dekarbonisierung des verkehrs redet
also über die frage wie man den verkehr
klimaneutral stellen kann
da kommen wir ohne elektroautos
eigentlich nicht weit hier gibt es aber
viele kommentare die ich lese die sagen
also wir haben ein problem mit den
batterien weil sie die art und weise wie
die hergestellt werden ist sehr
energiereich die art und weise wo die
rohstoffe dafür herkommen ist nicht
unbedingt immer ethisch korrekt oder
zumindest auch wenig umweltfreundlich
wie sieht's denn damit aus also wenn wir
nur an dem auto haben ein auto ist ja
nicht ihr auto oder also das stimmt die
batterien verursachen bei ihrer
herstellung mehr co2 emissionen das
heißt auch am anfang meines vaters
lebens hat ein elektroauto mehr
emissionen auf dem buckel wenn man so
will eines ein vergleichbarer verbrenner
diese werte sind in den letzten jahren
aber schon deutlich gesunken und sie
sinken auch weiter wir haben gerade eine
studie veröffentlicht wo es um die
reduktionspotenzial auch geht bei der
batterieherstellung unter sehen wäre
dass es noch 50 prozent einsparpotenzial
zum beispiel beim energieverbrauch gibt
der in den nächsten jahren also deutlich
reduziert werden kann und damit auch das
co2 bei der batterieproduktion sinkt ich
habe morgen kommentar da geht so auf die
richtung wie sollen die akkus entsorgt
werden in die dritte welt ländern und
kinder die nicht älter sind als 12 bis
15 jahren müssen
lithium und kobalt abbauen da mache ich
nicht mit sehen sie da irgendwie eine
entwicklung also es ist auf jeden fall
wichtig dass man die lieferketten genau
unter die lupe nimmt und dass man
verantwortung in der lieferkette
gesetzlich vorschreibt da sind wir auch
dafür und das wird gerade auf
europäischer ebene diskutiert in einem
gesetzgebungsprozess zur herstellung von
batterien
momentan gibt es da keine gesetzliche
vorschrift
wir finden man sollte verantwortung in
der lieferkette gesetzlich verbindlich
vorschreiben um hier solchen solchen
situationen wie kinderarbeit oder aber
auch umweltverschmutzung beim abbau von
rohstoffen entgegenzuwirken und den
riegel vorzuschieben aber weiter stelle
ich mir die frage warum denn jetzt
andere autohersteller auch vw vor allem
als größte automobilhersteller der welt
so voll nur auf diese e mobilität setzen
also es gibt ja noch andere
möglichkeiten brennstoffzellen es gibt
die so genannten iq ist also
synthetische brennstoffe wo man jetzt
nicht großartig etwas umstellen müsste
in der gesamten infrastruktur
warum wird vor allem auch von der
politik gerade diese e mobilität so
stark gefördert
ja das ist die politik ist glaube ich
nicht naja das kind den kaufantrag
stehen die flotten ziele der
europäischen union
die sind sehr hart sind jetzt auch noch
mal verschärft worden
und die machen einen enormen druck auf
die automobilindustrie der übrigens wie
man in dem beispiel ja sieht durchaus
hilfreich ist und wenn man sich jetzt
fragt wir sind technologieoffen aber
welche technologie soll es denn jetzt
seien dann landet man sehr schnell bei
dem thema das zum beispiel wasserstoff
aber auch us- wesentlich
energieintensiver sind das als ich
brauch wesentlich mehr energie um
dasselbe ergebnis zu erzielen
gerade dann wenn es am ende gehen muss
wenn wir hoffentlich die ganze erde in
energieerzeugung auf erneuerbare
energien umgestellt haben dann wird man
feststellen dass dafür auf absehbare
zeit nicht genug erneuerbare energien
zur verfügung stehen und das ist ein
ganz wesentlicher grund dafür warum
faktisch bei den pkws die frage richtung
batterie elektromobilität entschieden
worden ist das ist übrigens bei anderen
verkehrsträgern anders das gilt für
flugzeuge nicht das gilt für schiffe
nicht für trucks wird es auch nicht so
gelten aber bei pkw scheint es mir so zu
sein er ist das so frau meier gibt es da
keine alternative also ist tatsächlich
die batterie das energiesparende
fortbewegungsmittel der zukunft
die batterie hat enorme effizienz
vorteile gegenüber allen anderen
möglichkeiten von benzin und diesel
wegzukommen
das stimme ich herrn wald zu also wenn
sie strom basierte kraftstoffe
herstellen oder wasserstoff dann
brauchen sie schlichtweg viel mehr
windräder oder auch terawattstunden an
erneuerbarem strom als sie das brauchen
wenn sie mit elektroautos fahren und
deswegen zeigen eigentlich auch alle
wichtigen klimaschutz szenarien dass
elektroautos für die dekarbonisierung
des verkehrs eine ganz zentrale rolle
spielen und da sind jetzt aber schon bei
der nächsten zentralen rolle ich habe
hier mal den kommentar von thomas david
auf youtube rausgesucht können wir kurz
mal zeigen wer spricht nämlich das
anders wir gerade schon angesprochen
haben wo kommt der strom her wo sorgen
wird dafür dekarbonisierung also wie
sorgen wir dafür dass hier weniger co2
ausstoßen dennoch ist der deutsche
strommix doch ziemlich kohle lastig da
muss sich was ändern energiewende ist
ein stichwort derweil warum dauert das
so lange auch bei ihnen im bundesland
auch wenn sie das spitzenreiter sind ja
aber dass das ist tatsächlich die offene
flanke bei der ganzen energiewende bei
der klima wende bei der verkehrs brände
das alles braucht als fundament sehr
viele erneuerbare energien und da sind
die fortschritte die wir in den letzten
jahr zählte am schlichtweg nicht
ausreichend da muss man nicht
drumrumreden der leitungsausbau dauert
nach wie vor zu lange wir haben auch zu
viele hemmnisse
wenn wir beispielsweise über wind an
land also über onshore reden wir müssen
wahrscheinlich die planungen für
offshore wind wesentlich erhöhen und wir
werden auch nach wie vor ein energie in
portland bleiben also wir müssen auch
erneuerbare energien mit importieren und
an der stelle muss ich ehrlich sagen
sind die bemühungen insbesondere von
bundeswirtschaftsminister in den
vergangenen jahren schlichtweg
unzureichend gewesen
also die klimaschutzziele die sind
hingebungsvoll diskutiert worden aber
diese fundamentale fragen wie man sie
erreichen will
die ist wirklich ins hintertreffen
geraten und ich wünsche mir nach den
bundestagswahlen an der stelle wirklich
wesentlich mehr speed aber da könnten
sie ja im bundesland dass ich auch was
machen also die windkraftbranche bei
ihnen niedersachsen hat auch schon
kritisiert dass der ausbau der
windenergie zu schleppend läuft dass es
zu viel bürokratie sagen sie es dauert
zu lange
letztes jahr ist das ganze auch ins
stocken geraten unter anderem wegen
wegen anwohnern die gesagt haben wir
wollen die windräder nicht haben aber
eben auch wegen der zulassungs bewegen
können sie da nicht ein bisschen mehr
speed machen und sagen okay wir
entbürokratisieren das ganze naja bei
föderalismus sind wir natürlich im
rahmen des bundes systems auch an das
planungsrecht gebunden und das ist
tatsächlich sehr kompliziert wir haben
sie mit vielen ab währungsfragen zu tun
es gibt viel rechtsschutz in deutschland
und alles das führt dazu dass am ende
des tages projekte unendlich lange
dauern ich sage ihnen vielleicht dass
man einen praktisch relevanten beispiel
viele verfahren landen vor gericht wegen
der diskussion ist der artenschutz
hinreichend berücksichtigt worden
nun wird niemand von uns bestreiten
wollen hatte ich als allerletzter dass
artenschutz ein ganz wichtiges anliegen
ist nur wenn wir an der stelle fast
immer dem artenschutz dann den vorrang
geben dann darf man sich auch nicht
wundern wenn der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien am ende des tages zurück in der
energie- leitungsausbau das ist eine
generationenaufgabe ich finde das ist
einfach nicht hinnehmbar da zeigen auch
andere länder wie es schneller geht da
steht finde ich ein echtes stück
staatsreform an dass wir schneller
werden insbesondere auch um die
grundlagen für die klimawende zulegen
und da haben wir eine menge arbeit da
können wir nicht zufrieden sein was wir
bis jetzt geschafft haben was ist denn
da ihre ihre forderung oder ihre idee
frau maja ich habe gerade mal gelesen
ich jetzt so eine forderung von einem
user der sagt kernkraftwerke bauen
grundlastfähig und zuverlässig und da
gibt es ja durchaus wenn man einfach mal
ganz klar auf den co2 ausstoß guckt ich
mag ihren kommentar hier grad noch mal
dann wie die kernkraft war gar nicht so
schlecht da also kohle und gas liegen da
sehr viel schlechter also ist das
vielleicht dann doch ein fehler gewesen
sei auszusteigen wenn wir jetzt schnell
energie wechsel brauchen wir noch heute
gehört honda altmaier wir brauchen mehr
energie in den nächsten jahren als wir
gedacht haben
naja also der ausstieg aus der kernkraft
der wurde
vor einigen jahren mit ganz großer
parlamentarischer mehrheit beschlossen
und im übrigen auch mit großer
unterstützung bei wählerinnen und
wählern
ich halte das für eine unwahrscheinliche
idee dass man das jetzt wieder
rückgängig macht also noch einen
ausstieg aus dem ausstieg beschließt
aber wenn wir schon von ausstiegen
sprechen der kohleausstieg ist natürlich
ganz zentral also der muss auf jeden
fall jetzt bald kommen denn sonst
funktioniert das auch nicht was halten
sie denn von plänen her weil den
individualverkehr generell
runterzuschrauben wir haben ja gerade
schon gesagt also der öpnv muss weiter
ausgebaut werden ist schwierig in einem
flächenland wie niedersachsen aber auch
eine herausforderung die angegangen
werden muss was halten sie denn davon zu
sagen okay wir gucken dass dieser ganze
individualverkehr erstmals den
innenstädten verschwindet damit die
leute weniger anreize haben zum beispiel
auch in der stadt ein auto überhaupt zu
fahren
das geschieht tatsächlich für ab und das
verkehrsverhalten das verändert sich ja
auch sehr man sieht das glaube ich in
der jüngeren generation sehr deutlich
dann in dem alter in dem für mich ein
eigenes auto von zentraler persönlicher
bedeutung war
da haben viele junge leute gar keinen
führerschein weil sie kein brauchen weil
sie gute alternativen innerhalb den
städten haben aber sehr mit recht darauf
hingewiesen
auf dem land in der fläche sieht das
eben anders aus und da werden die
menschen auf absehbare zeit nach wie vor
auf ihr auto angewiesen seien
das soll dann aber bitteschön auch eins
sein dass auch wirklich zu klima positiv
beiträgt und darum geht es jetzt in den
nächsten jahrzehnt entscheidend glaube
es wird weniger großstadt thema sein als
außerhalb der großstädte stichwort
arbeitsplätze ist ja auch so eine frage
die immer wieder aufkommt da machen sich
einige sorgen wir haben das mal
zusammengefasst was das bedeuten könnte
denn jetzt hat sich nicht über leighton
zu diesen plänen von vw komplett auf
autos umzusteigen
elektroautos sind die zukunft doch unter
den beschäftigten der automobilbranche
sind sie auch als job killer gefürchtet
der grund in einem elektromotor werden
viel weniger teile verbaut als in einem
verbrennungsmotor weniger aufwand gleich
weniger personal so die befürchtungen
der belegschaft doch stimmt das wirklich
es herrscht ein wenig verwirrung denn
bei dem thema gibt es unterschiedliche
prognosen
mehr als 400.000 jobs sind in gefahr
warnt die gewerkschaft ig bce autos sind
keine jobkiller sagt hingegen eine
studie des fraunhofer instituts
sie vergleicht die produktion eines
konventionellen golfs mit dem neuen e
auto von vw den id3 ergebnis aufwand und
zeit für die herstellung unterscheiden
sich kaum
außerdem will vw so viele mitarbeiter
wie möglich auf elektroautos um schulen
sind e-autos also doch keine jobkiller
tja das ist die große frage und eine
kleine korrektur von mir der größte
autohersteller der welt ist toyota und
nicht volkswagen derweil ist das jetzt
ganze einen einen jobkiller programm was
der volkswagen konzern heute angekündigt
hat oder haben sie hoffnung dass sie die
arbeitsplätze niedersachsen halten
können also es verändert sich sehr viel
und die spannende frage bezahlen wie was
ist unter dem strich dann weiter richtig
ist dass electronista sie erstmal
deutlich weniger beschäftigungs intensiv
als der verbrenner
das liegt einfach daran bis jetzt war
der motor die wichtigste komponente
künftig ist er nicht mehr so relevant
beim elektroauto dafür die batterie umso
mehr und das ist zum beispiel der
springende punkt wenn künftig die
batterie das zentrale element ist dann
müssen wir die größte das größte
interesse daran haben dass die
entsprechende wertschöpfung bei uns in
deutschland stattfindet und dass da
arbeitsplätze entstehen
das wird zum teil geschehen jedenfalls
nach den plänen die volkswagen heute
vorgestellt haben aber nur zum teil bei
denen wir wirklich wollen dass es an der
stelle vorangeht dann wird eine
investition in deutschland schlichtweg
auch wettbewerbsfähig und wirtschaftlich
sein müssen
und da tun die europäischen nachbarn
ringsum deutschland wesentlich mehr als
derzeit in deutschland vorgesehen ist
und da würden wir große
beschäftigungspotenziale verschenken das
macht mir große sorge wettbewerbsfähig
und wirtschaftlich das klingt immer so
nach zu mir leid er verdient jetzt
weniger liebe arbeitgeber und nehmer na
ja es macht einen großen unterschied ob
die planung für eine batterie
zellproduktion in dem land iks mit ich
sage mal 700 millionen oder einer
milliarde am ende sogar unterstützt wird
und in dem land y überhaupt nicht dass
da eine geschäftsführung auch
schlichtweg nach ihren vorgaben
handeln muss das liegt auf der hand und
deutschland hat den großen vorteil
bislang dass die gesamte
wertschöpfungskette bei den autos in
unserem land abgebildet werden kann und
die sind sehr beschäftigungs intensiv
wenn wir uns den vorteil erhalten wollen
dann wird die bundesregierung und dieser
stelle ihr ein bisschen groß verändern
müssen waren wir dazu langsam ich hab
den kommenden tagen die richtung von 67
matze der schreibt da was waren
nebelkerzen solange man noch ein
verbrenner festhalten wollte sonst hätte
man hier batteriefabriken gebaut aber
das hat man den asiaten und tesla
überlassen also sind wir da auf dem
letzten waggon quasi gerade noch so
aufgesprungen na ja teils teils richtig
ist dass europa und deutschland naja ich
sage mal wahrscheinlich vor 20 jahren
oder so nicht rechtzeitig erkannt hat
dass es in diese richtung eben auch
gehen wird und dass man eine eigene
kompetenz zum beispiel in den
entsprechenden chemischen fragen aufbaut
da ist so etwas wie eine aufholjagd im
gange und die allerdings wirklich mit
volldampf die nächste generation von
batterien die kann schon in deutschland
produziert werden
das sind dann die sogenannten festkörper
batterien aber damit das geschieht da
muss man eben auch die entsprechenden
wettbewerbs bedingungen herstellen also
insgesamt gesehen hätte die deutsche
automobilindustrie früher mitmachen
müssen richtig aber es ist nicht zu spät
und es ist finde ich wirklich spannend
und beachtlich zu sehen wie viel da
schon einen rückstand aufgeholt worden
ist aber das ganze kann ja auch in die
adresse ihres parteifreundes olaf scholz
gehen der da als finanzminister sitzt
und da auch die entsprechenden anreize
schaffen könnte ja und des
bundeswirtschaftsministers und der
politik insgesamt am ende wird sich die
bundesebene
ich nehme an nach den bundestagswahlen
dafür entscheiden müssen ob sie sagt ja
wir kämpfen darum dass diese industrie
in deutschland entsteht samt ihrer
entsprechenden wertschöpfung oder wir
schauen zu wie das in europäischen
nachbarländern gesteht das kann man im
ernst nicht wollen wird die spd das tun
ja das hoffe ich sehr
also ich glaube das haus gibt es auch
eine feinwaage zweites mal es zu der
schönen klassischen beispielsweise für
die verbindung von arbeit und umwelt ist
das geschieht damit man künftig deutlich
weniger co2 ausstößt und wenn man die
arbeit halten will dann wird man da
entsprechend auch nachlegen müssen das
hoffen sie aber versprechen sie nicht
mit versprechen bin ich als
norddeutscher sowieso sehr vorsichtig
aber sie können wirklich sicher davon
ausgehen ja weil ich danke ihnen dass
sie heute zeit für uns hatten und uns
die fragen beantwortet haben wir sind
noch viele aufgelaufen aber als
ministerpräsident haben sie noch ein
paar termine heute abend deswegen bitte
ich um feuer das gerne wiederholen ist
kein problem das machen wir sehr gerne
dann kommen wir wieder auf sie zu und
auch sie zurück für heute aber vielen
dank und auch vielen dank an euch und
sie für die ganzen fragen und kommentare
es sind noch viele aufgelaufen das ist
ein thema was viele menschen beschäftigt
was uns auch die nächsten jahre
beschäftigen wird deswegen glaube ich
wird es nicht das letzte gespräch mit
letzten scream dazu gewesen sein aber an
der stelle sage ich erst mal jetzt für
heute
vielen dank das zu sehen was mitmachen
macht's gut